i heard today
you're gonna first start with a cover
song
sure and i was like i wonder what post
is gonna do why better man today what
are you thinking i remember
my brother jordan
he was a marine
and he was stationed in hawaii
and
we went out to go see him i was
12 13 maybe maybe
and he played this song
we were driving around
and this was on an island you could
drive around in a couple hours
and he played it and
i guess i just been thinking about that
a lot lately so when you hear better man
you think about your brother who is a
marine every moment and it makes me
[ __ ] cry is your brother still alive
yes sir he's just a beautiful man and he
introduced me to pearl jam in a big
[ __ ] way i can't wait for this i love
this song
[Music]
waiting
watching the clock it's four o'clock
it's got to start
[Music]
take no more she
practices her speech as she opens the
door
she rolls over pretends to sleep as he
looks
[Music]
can't find a better man
she dreams in color she changes me
can't find a better man
can't find a better man
[Music]
talking
to herself there's no one else who needs
to know she tells ourselves
[Music]
memories back when she
was born and strong waiting for her
to
come on
[Music]
swishy's he's
[Music]
dreams teens and red
call
she
can't find a better man
she lies it says she still loves him
can't find a better man
she dreams ain't cold as she screams and
rain
can't find a better man
can't find a better man
can't find a better way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that's why she'll
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
can't find a
better man
[Music]
[Music]
beautiful andrew wadden post malone's
thinking better man love you eddie i
love you too eddie